there are certain government programs
that are highly are these cigars by the
way I just noticed this over here you
can take it um if countries uh
spend money on Pro I I don't know you
seem to be looking something up I don't
know if you're paying I'm listening I'm
listening to you go ahead can I take a
sip yeah is that an energy drink now it
is owned by Tesla by the way too yeah
no it's not I don't so for example just
to pick two different programs I don't
have any emotional attachment to these
two programs I'm just going to list two
programs food stamps and what is
happening in here by the way or are
those gummies yeah taking vitamins man
this is this is healthy for you I know I
don't want to be the 400 pound guy food
stamps have a high economic multiplier
David you have to know I can't wait to
have you the next time around I can't
wait to have a different kind of
conversation because I think the next
one's going to be better than this one
because now we kind of have an idea now
we know each other and I can come
prepared we can talk energy drinks
cigars and supplements yeah